my question comes from the movie contact
one of my favorites the problem I'm
trying to figure out is the ending when
Jodie Foster's character travels in the
spaceship and has her experience but for
Earth viewers the ship instantly falls
through like nothing happened and then
it is later revealed that her camera
recorded 18 hours of static now from
what I understand about relativity it
should have been opposite on earth 18
hours would would have passed but her
camera would have recorded seconds of
static please help me put my mind at
rest on this query once and for all did
the movie get that part wrong or am I
missing something this person knows just
enough relativity to just get angry
about it yeah so just to remind people
in the film yeah Jodie Foster's
character visits aliens in another part
of the galaxy
and does so in an odd sort of rotating
spaceship that never leaves Earth and
they see her take just seconds and in
that time in those few seconds she goes
on this journey and I think the point
here is that the fabric of space and
time yeah is such that you can warp
either space or time or both and so you
can basically travel through a wormhole
get to some destination instantly mm-hmm
all right and if you travel fast that
you're the question who is it who is it
that in Danny did we swear uh I don't
know but the name is definitely Danny
luden so normally if you're the Nama
Kirky if you're the one that goes away
you live for a shorter amount of time
than Earth that you've left behind so
Danny is perfectly correct about that
but these are aliens who gave us
instructions how to build a spaceship to
do exactly what just happened so I'm not
worried about that relative time
dilation of Danny's right that it would
logically work that way unless aliens
gave him a plan that he stuck to that
worked differently
exactly which is what happened in the
film I could also imagine that she was
not the one who left that it was earth
that left that location
and then return I mean and then birth is
the one that that lives further only a
few moments and he's the one that lives
longer you can imagine aliens
controlling space and time in such a way
that that's what happens so so in the
movie they could have moved the whole
planet with that would be large it would
be Lauren saying it's easy man I'm not
saying this is easy sage that it would
then possibilities are what I what I
mean is that it would be hard not only
to physically move the planet but earth
has to be the one that accelerates away
and then like slows down stops and comes
back we would all feel that you would
feel that yes if we went through a
wormhole we would feel it so if we
slowed down we sped up and slowed down
and stopped we would just fall over and
roll roll off the planet because we're
not attached to the earth so not even a
little no not at all not even with not
even gravity so we would all fly away if
you could stop the earth if you just
stop the earth from this movement in
space or it's adjusted it in some way
yeah
earth would stop but we were moving with
the earth in orbit around I'll just fly
very quickly and as do you would fly
through a dashboard in a car that hits a
brick wall and you're not working so I
really can't believe that like people
who do like jump from outer space or
bungee jump ready that haven't tried to
stop earth to just go flood wouldn't be
able to feel it fun experiment try it so
I'm not worried about that but strictly
speaking if she was the one that went
away
Danny's correct oh yeah mm-hmm all right
Danny good job